[Music]
donnelly order can yer ism is a widening
of the aorta as it courses out of the
heart and down through the abdomen to
eventually supply blood to the lower
extremities patients are found to have
an aneurysm it's usually incidentally
when they come in for some other reason
the end up with a cat scan or an
ultrasound or some form of an x-ray that
finds them incidentally a lot of times
they're called silent killers for that
reason because most times most people
don't know they have them when we do
find them we tend to surveil them very
closely by far the three biggest risk
factors are being male age and the
biggest risk factor is history of
cigarette smoking so once an aneurysm
reaches threshold to be repaired there's
two ways of fixing it there is the
traditional way which is open repair
where we open up the aneurysm and
replace the native a Horta with a tube
graft technology has come a long way and
we do it what's called endovascular
approach and that's where we go in
through the femoral arteries and with
wires and catheters and we realign the
aorta from the inside with a stent graft
and that essentially excludes the
aneurysm from the circulation screening
is completed through a very simple
ultrasound usually takes very little
time 10 to 15 minutes to complete that
scan it's read by a radiologist and with
very good accuracy can identify those
who have an aneurysm and what follow-up
we should have from there
[Music]
you